[Musique]
les gens diront que près de la vie si
tout compte qu'on est astucieux peine
c'est le plus sérieux les cas ça me
à jouer aujourd'hui il suffit de vouloir
revenir à un ami
ah oui ah oui effectivement soleil tu
sais j'ai besoin de mettre en forme
maintenant on travaille à bon d'accord
oui
finie la rigolade c'est fini bonjour toi
tard qu un pic en double menton bull
bull ou l'emprunt que ce soit dans le
jeu graphique le jeu géographique
deviner un pays à partir de sa carte
géographique de son drapeau et de la
façon dont on dit bonjour dans la langue
du pays note fabrice oui écoute un peu
non picot double qu'est ce qui fait que
ça veut dire ça n'a ni queue ni très
réduit avec vous d'avoir réduit avec
vous oui mais alors tu restes là tu ne
dis rien ah bon et d'avoudrey tout et
quand même et ben tu me diras que les le
pays en question a pas d'accord alors
regardez ici attention à temps je
commence avec la carte géographique du
pays considéré le voilà c'est bordé par
la mer encore oui c'est un pays avec une
grande façade maritime comme on dit en
termes géographiques
tu vois là la capitale est ici ou là
voici le drapeau de ce pays
pour ceux qui n'ont pas la couleur je
précise que nous avons ici le vert ici
le rouge et que le motif central et
jaune
journée rouge enfin jaune en grande
partie voilà puis pas commode pour moi
ça c'est pas facile pour personne ne
regarde tout de même c'est un pays qu'on
connaît bien ça et enfin bon jour dans
la langue de ce pays ça se dit alors la
prononciation diaz bones dias peut-être
en mariage je prononce pas très bien
bronze bondi à ce mondial
tu sais quel est ce pays toit puis quand
vous il ya les espagnols à diderot ne te
fais pas de train de péter le portugal
oui a haussé le ton samedi remarqué par
tibet m'a fait partie mais pas avec ici
la capitale lisbonne
parfaitement lisbonne ici bravo aux pics
en boule c'est bien joué d avance - moi
je ne mange que solidaires de courir
après les gens mènent le petit pic on
bouge oui il ya le fait oui abrite 2
pourrait revenir
oui tout à leur honneur d'or reviendrait
oui il est tout à leur honneur
allez hop on dans la luzerne oui c'est
ça oui il m'avait dit lui nous lui
laissons pas trop de temps donné qu'il
est fabrice une appli oui j'arrive une
seconde je suis occupé de deux mètres
dans la terre ça pour s'amuser avec
pique en bois
oui alors fabrice a misé une figure toi
que piquants goût piquant bull a voulu
que je les dépose dans un massif de
fleurs alors il a fallu que je trouve le
plus beau massif de fleuves et et de la
luzerne et ben oui bien ils voulaient
pas aller plus haut c'est bon film
nous sommes prêts pour le jeu du point
commun oui je vais commencer barthou
cancan belles belles et pousse moussu ce
sont des choses différentes
quel est le point commun entre un et
voit la bombe à ses traits c'est très
difficile avant je suis quelque chose de
très mais de très solides
on ne demande de ne jamais trembler
donne jamais mais fonderie même si on
fait peser sur moi des points énormes et
j'en vois passer des choses sur des
voitures des trains des camions as tu tu
peux me rencontrer un peu partout en
france et ailleurs tu as encore plus de
chance d'ailleurs de me rencontrer
si tu te promènes là où il ya un fleuve
c'était comme je dois être très fort tu
portes bien que je suis généralement en
fer ou en pierre bien que quelquefois on
est fabriqué en boire mais dans ce cas
là je n'accepte pas tout le monde mais
oui voilà c'est tout c'est toy
alors moi je suis très nerveuse judo
était tellawi jus sans moi une porte une
vigueur que j'ai envie de communiquer
tout le monde c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'on m'apprécie et qu'on utilise il ya
des quotités de petites machines des
petits appareils qui sont en moi restera
immobile mais je m'approche jeu est doux
et aussitôt il se met à fonctionner je
suis vraiment une bienfaitrice japon
la lumière j'apporte ce sont j'apporte
la vieille je n'ai hélas qu'un seul
défaut
je ne suis pas éternel petit à petit je
perds mes forces et on doit me remplacer
[Musique]
alors là là je suis bien embêté parce
que ça correspond pas ce que je pensais
oui bah moi moi fabrice je suis sûr
qu'en ce moment tu m'as dans ta poche
oui presque tout le monde dans sa poche
d'ailleurs on ne fait pas attention à
moi où on donne on reprend en échange on
est plus heureux de nous voir arriver
que de me voir partir mais tout de même
on ne pleure pas quand je m'en vais il
ya même des gens qui jouent avec moi il
me lance en l'air
il regarde comment je vais retombées
c'est pas toujours amusant pour moi on
ne fait tourbillonner et et on attend
que je me cogne par terre à la face à ça
finit par faire mal et ça m'a bim avec
une vie paraiba les beaux dessins qu'on
fait sur moi mais on ne voit plus on
aimerait plus est
et crois moi ils sont beaux ils sont
très très beau cd ça oui il ya des rois
il ya des emplois il ya des présidents
des procédés profils de femmes des
fleurs genre tu sais je représente de
l'argent ou de l'argent représente non
pas du tout parce que toi tu commences à
me parler tout concorde une chose qui
manifestement devrait être un pont
[Musique]
bah écoute franchement oui mais qu'est
ce qu'ils aiment pas tous et c'est bien
le pompage pour le point à lévis yeux
à oui oui oui on voulait parler d'une
pizza
oui je ne pas être déguerpis
c'était dur en fait c'est et piles pour
la pièce debout sous la pile d'un pont
et puis toi c'était quoi le pilbois toi
et bien moi j'ai une pile ilic défection
oui oui a dit on va sur moitié battu la
jambe
il faut reconnaître qu'à moitié mais
très difficile très difficile
oui ça c'est nouveau mais j'avais ma
petite soeur vous écouter ah bon abbas
et 1 c'était difficile nous a pas souri
mais pourrait aussi s'appeler pile ou
face
[Musique]
bah voilà
bon à vrai dire mon écoute oui ça suffit
maintenant
ouais bon vin chante amusante mais dites
donc il faudra peut-être pourquoi
s'arrêter
ea sont bavardes allait bel bel va faire
ce que tu as font alors le fameux riches
fabrice faudrait peut-être penser à
notre jeu parce que oui il faut y aller
voilà les nerfs d'acier talent il est
trop tard le ciel va tomber puis après
mais elle est très bon alors tu vas au
tableau la preuve qu'il est déjà combien
de la combien de lettres
s'il est cette semaine s'il s s'il est
trop facile et ça doit les alors ça doit
aller dans sera les tableaux premières
lettres ans il est alors la première c1
au 1o voilà ou alors un deux trois elia
tu es la dernière lady la dernière et
accent aigu 1e accent aigu és voilà
voilà
alors voilà temps oui n'auriez pas pu
fermer la porte excusez moi une petite
seconde 1 franchement là que je des
courants d'air si oui alors moi
j'attrape des courants d'air d'avoir
froid voilà alors est ce que c'est un
animal non c'est pas un animal est ce
que c'est une
une plante aussi c'est plus que ça et
plus qu'une plante à une fleur non non
alors puisque ça un arbre plus grand 1 à
revoir à nana c'est un c'est un arbre de
nos régions
est ce que c'est un arbre quelqu'un de
bons fruits
oui quoi des fruits qu'est ce que tu as
à nonant hanoi a pas de fruits des
annonces et panneaux qui donnent des
fruits tu veux te donne la troisième
lettre
oui par la 3e net c'est un i j oui c'est
pas un art qui donnent des fruits mais
c'est un bel arbre arista bénard est
sûre qu'ils donnent pas de fruit un coup
quand ils donnent pas de fruits bah ça
vous concentrer enfin rio paris est ce
que c est ce que c'est un art du midi
oui mais non lui dit écoute là je
verrais bien quelque chose qui vient
tout de suite à l'esprit d'abord ça
s'écrit pas comme ça commence à intégrer
pas comme ça c'est pas un olivier
même si bien sûr voyons tu as trouvé un
olivier ou le excusé encore une fois
mais ça faut tu sais pas écrire j'ai
encore fait une foule bon enfant écoute
olivier n'est ce pas ça s'écrit comme ça
ouais j'y arriverai jamais je vais
jamais y e et r ouais et les olives
d'après toi c'est pas son corps des
fruits d'un olivier les olives à bâle
alors tu en as tu mets des tours et
barres women à leur branchement
l'oreille à ceux qui veulent perdre
certains et nombre 1
si les olives sont sur six mois j'ai
toujours cru que les olives et moi je
savais le barbier
moi je n'ai pas en visite touche en vue
que dans des petits bols et wiba aux
chambres taillées petit beaucoup oui oh
oui je le dis points à ben j'arrive
j'arrive tout de suite j'ai tout de
suite été mauvais tout les deux à nous
fabrice piège mais avec moi là c'est
facile la musique et sa famille à 5,2 me
samassa doré panja femmes ont passé leur
est bien celle là ça se la dorer apple
alors bien dosé de jeu notre petit j'ai
des notes de musique cabri pour tanner
aussi ou plutôt pour commencer gitano et
j'ai pris une grande décision à bois une
décision je mets le 6 1
attends je vais fait tomber et bien à 6
la voie là et j'ai l'intention de faire
très prochainement une groupe de
randonnée randonnée avec un petit peu
d'accent un aller randonner voilà oisive
et partir vers le sud et givet le plus
loin possible
a big kate winslet d'ici de oui si tu
veux j'irai vers l'espagne au les moules
est aussi de franchir les pipes menée en
libye est libre
parvenu à la costa del
la costa del sol oui constat même sens
l'ouïe ou alors je visiterai le
roupillon le commun le roi lion l'euro
sinon rocinha mais les opinions étaient
plus rigoler un peu et puis surtout je
découvrirai la charmante propre beauté
dans à nous avons là la principauté
sinon eh bien allons d'andorre ballon et
bat avec un dos attention si ça et puis
allons je continuerai jusqu'à
l'extrémité de l'espagne et plus juré je
ne suis pas moi un peuple bleu
en quoi un lait à ce serait pas aussi si
le seuil soit là donc c'est pas
l'extrémité de l'espagne la sicile
s'apitoie l'extrémité de l'italie non
pas parce que tu donnes contrat oui
alors aussi attend jeu mais si oui et je
mets encore 1,6 oui et je le mets pas au
sud de l'espagne aussi pourquoi qu'est
ce que ça peut faire ce serait
finalement oui tu es toi aimer voir des
toits rapidos mais pourquoi la paire
rapidos ben je sais pas ce qui va
arriver à très lentement
on a servi l'état du ciel quelle
merveille une wii pardonnez-moi mais
leur part oui alors nous va chanter
est-ce que rapide de ce choc avec nous
non je suis essayé vous dis bon alors si
tu veux si tu veux j'arrive et du tunnel
jean bart est alors bien échapper mais à
côté de moi les top là ni sont déjà aux
copains aux amis les caps a dit qu'il
secret de la vie chère s'est désisté et
j'ai shop se déchausse les comme juni
patinoire il faudra faire attention les
gars ça ne se contentent côté sont
réunis les caps a mis sont heureux car
ils aiment la vie
oui
[Musique]
mais gagner
avais tu as joué aujourd'hui c'est le
vouloir je me dis qu'un ami ici de
vouloir devenir un ami
et la vidéo
plekanec et d'entre eux maintenant